welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and moon knight episode 3's ending
has huge consequences for the mcu as a
whole as the moon god conscious appears
to have casually sent the entirety of
mcu earth back in time a couple of
millennia to help steve and layla
stargaze like they used to when
sarcophagi were all the rage but what
could these consequences mean for our
upcoming phase 4 mcu titles well lucky
for us we are the speculation nation are
we not so all aboard everybody because
the train is about to leave the
speculation nation station my nerd
babies because the sheer gravity of this
last moon night episode needs to be
explained but hey before you do that
make sure to check out our new latest
obsession moon night shirt it is not
going to last forever so head on to new
rockstarsmerch.com you can pick that up
before it goes away because kanchu he
really wants his shirts he's like all
right i'll let you guys have a little
bit but you know what if you don't keep
it taken i'm going to bring it back to
the moon for me and captain america i'm
gonna wear it ourselves
now before we talk about the
consequences of steve and konchu's sky
turning we should probably talk about
what the hell is even happening in this
scene here so to recap moon9 episode 3
has yatseel the human avatar to the
egyptian goddess of love music in the
sky hathor telling mark that arthur
harold's long sought-after tomb of amit
was marked by an ancient magi named
senpu like two thousand years ago
according to the nerdy steve grant a
majority named senfo he was tasked with
recording the location of the tomb in
case the gods ever changed their minds
and decided to show mercy senfo marked
that tomb like 2 000 years ago and stars
drift over time not much as far as stars
go but it can mean the difference
between us searching miles and miles
away from where we're supposed to be
looking but in order for steve and layla
to get the exact location of amit's tomb
they would need to use the constellation
map that they found inside senpu's own
coffin with the night sky as it was
those two thousand or so years ago in
the past but here's the thing you can't
just have the sky be exactly the way it
was 2 000 years ago when you want to
especially considering how over the
centuries stars flicker out and die even
to this day a lot of the stars that we
see in the sky have already died
thousands of years ago and the earth as
steven puts it drifts off a bit so in
order for the light from the stars to be
exactly the way they were on the night
this old magi sunfu went a tomb market
those 2000 years ago is for the entire
planet to have gone back in time you
know doctor strange what if episode 4
style and steve and konshu used the moon
and its relationship to gravity to do
just that so let's break down what
happened here my nerd babies because
first consu tells steve to copy the way
his hands are positioned with steve
positioning his arms kind of like doctor
strange does when he uses the time stone
preceded by this huge amazing light show
in the sky as this massive glowing
purple ring appears wobbling super fast
over everybody now the biggest and most
obvious question here is what the hell
is even this purple ring anyway well uh
that's the freaking moon guys like
that's that's the moon the purple ring
is the moon like for the second time
this episode konshu the god of the moon
moved the moon not the sky but the moon
specifically for the purposes of moving
the entire planet to the exact
conditions that the universe was the
night senpu looked up at that night sky
to mark ahmet's tomb because check out
this moment when we get a zoom in on
steve's hand here because remember those
weird purple glowing dots that appeared
in the sky well if you look closely
those are actually the phases of the
freaking moon a moon that is just moving
really fast and that is specifically
responding to even the slightest
movements of steven's fingers as he
wields control of that moon and the moon
is moving around the planet in response
to whatever the hell konju is doing to
the earth's gravity to send the planet
back in time because remember earlier in
the episode when konchu first summons
the egyptian council of the gods by
creating a freaking solar eclipse by
moving the moon the only way for kanchi
to do this is to somehow manipulate the
way gravity works in relation to planet
earth to travel through time much like
i've suspected doctor strange does
through the use of the time stone in
what if an infinity stone which i have
theorized in the past is actually the
mcu's gravity stone due to gravity's
relationship with space-time in the
natural universe like for example the
more gravity an object has the slower
time tends to move like if you have not
watched my video explaining how each
infinity stone energy color represents a
scientifically core aspect of our
material universe i highly recommend
that you watch my first new rockstars
video on what i call the marvel trigger
theory to get more information on mcu
gravity because i really get into it
more there spoiler alert it's how shang
chi's mom and aunt look like they're
airbending and [ __ ] it's really cool
stuff go check that video out this video
is brought to you by the ridge the ridge
wallet is light sleek and industrial and
it's designed to fit in your front
pocket unlike those bulky old old school
wallets that make you look like you're
smuggling an 80s car phone in your back
pocket it's ridiculous check this out
nice and sleek there are over 30 colors
and styles including carbon fiber and
burnt titanium and it holds up to 12
cards and still has room for cash in the
back and every ridge wallet comes with a
lifetime guarantee and that lets you
test drive it for 45 days and send it
back for a full refund if you don't love
it which you will and the wallets have
over forty thousand five star reviews
and it's made with rfid blocking
technology that protects you from
digital pickpocketers and they also have
other cool products like this commuter
backpack it's weatherproof and great for
toting around a laptop and this month
marks nine years since the ridge started
and they're celebrating with a special
sale so get 15 off today with free
worldwide shipping and free returns by
going to ridge.com new rockstars that's
ridge.com new rockstars and use the code
new rockstars find the link in this
video's description and we thank bridge
again for sponsoring this video if you
remember everything around animated
doctor strange went back in time when he
used the gravity manipulating time stone
so that he could see christine palmer so
in that same respect everything around
earth like all the stars and planets and
lights in the universe everything went
back in time as well everything but the
people on earth and earth itself that
all being said let's get into the
consequences because boy oh boy they're
gonna be some consequences for these
shenanigans because uh you can't make a
whole planet go back in time
contradiction against the biggest
consequence of this moon gods meddling
is of course the return of the infinity
stones to the marvel cinematic universe
because prior to the destruction in
avengers end game by thanos off-screen
the infinity stones have been around the
universe since the beginning of the
universe with the big bang this being
said if the earth is two thousand years
into the universe's past the infinity
stones should be exactly where they were
those two thousand years ago the power
stone should be on morag the time stone
would likely be in possession of the
ancient one the tesseract would be in
odin's vault the ether would be hidden
in king bore's secret spot where jane
foster found it in thor 2 the mind stone
would likely be in possession of the
chitauri and the soul stone of course
being the one exception due to its
costly nature so like you know you
basically just have to forge that on
vormir but luckily this is still around
1 000 years before the very birth of
thanos the mad titan himself so you know
that really won't be humanity's problem
for a long while but this does mean that
thanos is technically back on the table
technically along with the resurrection
of thanos homeworld of titan which as we
learn in avengers infinity war was
destroyed due to titan's resource
problem so technically thanos's parents
alars who gets a shout out in avengers
infinity war and suicide might be alive
as well but you know brody's still
probably gonna have to wait a thousand
years to become the choking hazard that
he's always wanted to be
but moving on titan is of course not the
only civilization returning to the mcu
in this scenario because the planet of
xandar should very much be restored
after its destruction by the hands of
thanos in infinity war however what's
important to note here with xandar is
that this is before xandar's war with
the cree a war that would go on to last
a thousand years and of course kill a
ton of ronan the accuser's ancestors
causing him to become a crazy religious
zealot in 2014 which leads to the events
of guardians of the galaxy so it would
appear that the marvel cinematic
universe is setting up the stage for
their upcoming nova project by bringing
the full force of the nova corps back on
the map so maybe we're looking at a nova
core origin story with this new nova
project that'd be dope and maybe this
time somebody from earth could uh tip
the nova core off about that whole i
don't know eagle-living planet problem
because the worst dad of all time that
is an omni man is back baby because ego
of the living planet is like a bajillion
years old same with malikith from for
the dark world he's probably just out
there sleeping which i personally really
love because i truly do believe that
christopher eccleston deserves another
shot at this role because malikip is
actually a super tragic character if you
really think about it because he's just
trying to get rid of the colonizers
basically cosmic killmonger and of
course the realm of asgard returns to
the mcu as well as it is now several
centuries before surtur would destroy
the entire land during the events of
four ragnarok so i don't foresee the
people of new asgard staying in tonsburg
norway for much longer after the events
of thor love and thunder when they could
be big ballin back on the bifrost bridge
why would you not do that i wouldn't
want to live like a peasant when i could
be eating grapes amongst the unicorns in
the sky watching the peasants on mid
gods suffer with taxes but this
unfortunately means the return of the
baddest chick the mcu has ever seen
hella the goddess of death because as of
this point in mcu history she is still
being imprisoned by odin the all father
actually kind of freshly imprisoned sort
of just happened around this time an
all-father who should be now seated on
the throne of asgard all the way up on
the physical realm of asgard completely
unaware that king valkyrie rules another
asgard on earth so could we be looking
at a multiversal asgardian war between
these two variant asgards hmm it would
be pretty cool it would be kind of sad
but it'd be pretty cool will king
valkyrie have to fight the very valkyrie
sisters that she drowned herself in
liquor on sakar to forget because
they're all back too like they didn't
get killed by hela until 950 a.d and
this is like way before that but one of
the biggest consequences of this rewind
has got to be earth's apparent
disappearance from space entirely from
the perspective of everyone who wasn't
on earth when steve and consu sent earth
back in time which means potentially
that thor the guardians of the galaxy
and the eternals kidnapped by eresham
could return to an earthless milky way
in their timeline because konchu and
sieve moved the earth back in time
effectively branching the mcu into two
main timelines one with an earth and one
without an earth at all which you know
might come in handy if airshim doesn't
like what cersei's memories have to say
and wants to destroy earth and he just
comes back he's like oh shoot there's no
earth never mind um i guess we'll go
but anyways that is what i think the
biggest consequences are from this super
crazy episode of moon night which i
think is on par with the snap like this
is a huge event in mcu history i mean it
could be anyway i mean i obviously could
be wrong but let me know what you guys
think in the comment section below you
guys think that we went back in time let
us know in the comment section i wanna
know what you guys think but thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
really weird [ __ ] and really fun
theories but most importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
social media and when you do on youtube
make sure you hit that notification bell
so that you can get notifications
whenever we upload a video and of course
hit up newrockstarsmerch.com so that you
can get our really cool latest obsession
moonlight shirt because it's not going
to last forever people it's not people
always complain like hey oh what
happened to the loki shirts oh what
happened to the
other shirts spider-man shirts guys
these don't last forever please i can't
help you if they go okay just go get
them because this is my favorite shirt
but again thank you guys so much for
spending time with me i love you guys so
much and i'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
you